модератор спостереження оксана григорівна
гусєва
прошу тут криму цієї страх ланової краса
в ряду я святий виходьте із села я можу
сказати що заняттям і різьбленим і видам і
ми з тест на сидить і наеб а реван теж
не в школі скільки на вкладці
та могутній вантажу монтажу то початковий
процес друку ви і школи в роті до
дати роки на заняття дітей найрізноманітнішим і
видам і миси саме через не вийдемо з
тест можна ви червонуватий я казахи
впав на ванни дітьми в душі легкий
такі не нав'язуй форумі та нашим і
наук та
і математику і молу набагато лівша і
найпростіший можна з примати через
образотворче мистецтво через музику обидва
поїду та чий розум
інтегр затишку та веде діяльності
коментарів щодо даної програми
майстерності не було дуже багато ви на не
було критичним і там ще сам курс але
передача я творче заняття дітей за 1000
вимагатимуть самої did i do to the
діяльності мені більше подумайте
самих такому вітті алея можна все cum
on the річку робить вона такі групи
значить коментарі стус у нас тусувалася
про ітан я такого в 4к вже паху все-таки
травня викладатися і предмет сама б ти
фахівець у образі творчості обидва
спеціаліст музика вам природному що
хтось один військового ти я keys але та 1
ядро і можу ціни буду на основі чіткого
нуарний результат в результаті пропустити
тусувалась а то ващук росія викладок і
про краєм образу творчого атома зичним
природи алея
ідею інтеруван ня з їх вийдемо запаси
чита стива курсу майстерності офіс пиль
немає м і якіо бідний
тепер немає м маяки в результаті може ч
з рибалок і свого роду чий театральний
кузей аль не з дітей знову такі і
сам знайду біт повідай авік у дітей
початку ви і школи црв канонір лая
kiehl's ти ще про міхур this
тусувалась а шуму саме в програмі
погоджується на тому удивить і мою мучили
дати а баби нема кого картини
the razor обруча Шевченка шпалери краще
народні пісні отже за раз дуже багато з
у приватних гарних не занудних з цілих
дитину чиїх писати далі дуже багато тварі
2 дітей з жахливим та засобом знаємо і ти
церес не техніки змитий
що їм буду йти до ву і кури сну могутній
хочеться туди ти що ж мета курс
на жаль але ця група команд atari
іванова логіка святкуєте його
ну навичка заарештовувати і мабуть а
все-таки у криму ви кладете ці дві
дисципліни
ще хотілося б туди ти че krank such as
новому природі обов'язково дітей потрібно
знаємо це з міц цілим і майстра ми з
місяці ви ми художниками і зал навчають їх
ду активну діяльність usa минулого
таких-то проведення майстер-класу
силах у програма Чикаго і Дейн ти грубо
не завжди погоджувалась attack червону я хуем